[Music]
hi in this video i'll introduce you to
data stream
then i'll walk through setting up a
stream from oracle to cloud storage
i'm gabe weiss a developer advocate for
google cloud
datastream is a serverless change data
capture or cdc
and replication service datastream makes
it easy to synchronize data across
heterogeneous databases and applications
reliably
and with minimal latency datastream
provides a simple
integrated experience to guide you
through every step of the process
it's serverless so you don't need to
worry about managing or monitoring
instances
and continuous data replication means
you can unify data across multiple
sources and applications
and make it accessible in real time it
helps power a wide range of use cases
including data replication for analytics
database migrations
event driven architectures ai and
machine learning data lakes and many
more
whether your source database is
on-premises self-hosted in google cloud
or running on another cloud
data stream helps you quickly unlock the
benefits of real-time cdc
now let's walk through the data stream
experience you can easily find data
stream by searching for it in the search
box at the top of the cloud platform
console
you can also find it from the google
cloud console navigation under
big data to get started you'll create a
stream
this represents the end-to-end process
of streaming changes from your source
database to your destination
first let's define some basic
information about the stream i want to
ingest data from an oracle database i
have running on gce
to a cloud storage destination
once i've defined my source and
destination types data stream shows me
the configuration required for
successful streaming
data stream is unique in that it
reflects all of the source and
destination configuration requirements
directly within the creation process to
take out the guesswork involved
for example since i chose oracle as my
source i can see the requirements for
setting up the necessary login
configurations and permissions on oracle
[Music]
after confirming the necessary
prerequisites i'm ready to define my
source
i can do this by creating a connection
profile a resource that represents the
information needed to connect to a
database
these profiles aren't locked to an
individual stream this means
i can reuse profiles if i want to and
also allows me to hand off creating the
source configuration to someone else my
organization who's in charge of
connecting to the database
i've already created a connection
profile for an oracle database running
on google cloud's vm
so i'll select it whether i create my
source connection profile now or use the
one i create in advance
i can test connectivity to make sure the
data stream is able to reach it
datastream supports both public and
private connectivity methods to easily
and securely connect to sources whether
they're hosted
be it on google cloud on-premise or on
other cloud providers
once the connectivity test passes i can
continue to configure the stream for my
source
next i want to select the objects that
this stream should pull from my source
using the selection ui i can define
which schemas and tables to stream from
my oracle source
i will select the entire hr schema and a
couple of tables from the movie schema
for the objects i selected i also need
to bring over the historical data
so i leave the backfill historical data
enabled
now i'm ready to define the destination
for my stream here again
i can create a new connection profile
for my destination or use an existing
one
i'll select a gcs bucket i have ready to
go
now data stream allows me to specify a
path within my cloud storage bucket
where the stream data will be stored
for this demo i want files to be written
to the root folder of the bucket
data stream allows me to find the right
balance between file size
and data freshness that's right for my
use case it's important for me to have
my data available quickly so i'll reduce
the writing delay to destination to 15
seconds
this means the files written to gcs will
be smaller but the data will be
available faster
well that was easy i've connected and
configured my stream all this left is to
validate the end to end stream
configuration and start moving data
validation passed successfully i can
trust that my stream will run smoothly
i'll create and start the stream to run
it immediately
[Music]
once my stream is created i can monitor
its progress and see if it encounters
any issues
data stream will perform the historical
backfill and continuously replicate
changes as they happen
i can monitor different metrics of the
stream such as throughput latencies and
more
that's it i've quickly and easily shown
you how to continuously ingest changes
from an oracle database into cloud
storage using data stream
and since data stream is serverless
it'll automatically scale up and down to
handle my data volume and maintain
minimal latency
with change data now continuously
streaming into cloud storage
i can easily leverage products like
dataflow to process the data as needed
for example i could use a purpose-built
template to replicate the data into
bigquery or cloud sql for postgres
data stream is the fast easy and
reliable way to seamlessly deliver
change data streams from your database
to google cloud
to support analytics database
replication and event driven
architectures
it's serverless high performance and
easy to use
now it's your turn to give it a try you
can get started from the google cloud
console or
learn more at cloud.google.com
datastream
thanks for watching